billard baby foot jeux vidéo et si nous
ne sommes pas dans un service jeunesse
mais dans un service d'accueil d'urgence
pour un adolescent ouverts depuis un an
ce service départemental on reçoit
quatre filles et quatre garçons âgés de
14 à 18 ans dans 90% des cas ces
adolescents sont placés dans cet
établissement sur décision judiciaire
il reste trois mois le temps de se
reconstruire là je sors pas donc shebab
et si je n'ai pas en danger cherche un
travail pour l'année prochaine ce que je
faisais pas quand j'étais chez moi j'ai
le périple des éducateurs spécialisés
sont présents 24 heures sur 24 dans ce
foyer robert carpentier situé à
versailles un service d'urgence et
accepter le fait d'être séparé de sa
famille quelle que soit la raison et de
pouvoir imaginer la façon dont ils vont
pouvoir rebondir pour demain il ya
plusieurs portes de sortie c'est un
retour en famille donc au tour dans le
milieu naturel famille élargie de ce que
c'est pas forcément les parents en tant
que tel après il ya des foyers des
foyers ce qu'on appelle des maisons
d'enfants à caractère social des
familles d'accueil des lieux de vie ou
alors effectivement pour certains jeunes
des séjours de rupture à l'étranger
cette aide aux adolescents est une
mission obligatoire du conseil général
qui consacre 7 5 millions d'euros au
fonctionnement de ce service d'urgence
et des structures départementales
concédant que nous trouvons ici la
maison de l'enfance et puis il ya des
structures aussi associative qui sont
dans l'ensemble du département voire
voir au delà du des limites
territoriales du département
le budget global de pratiquer son
enfance dans le département des villes
et de 80 millions d'euros qui sont
principalement les prix de journée que
nous payons au
aux structures d'accueil des enfants qui
sont placés deux établissements opecst
et un autre qui sortira de terre à
mantes-la-jolie au premier semestre 2015
remplacement ce foyer limité en nombre
ils pourront accueillir 26 adolescents